well hello Anthony hey how's it going
it's going good it's nice to see you in
season 2 thank you so much your carbon
coming in in this way
having that your characters already
established you're taking him on as a
new sleeve what's that like for you
doing that kind of coming in a unique
way uh it was a lot of fun actually I
feel like will and joel has set up this
character perfectly and this season is
very different and emotion wise so I had
to kind of take that stoic revenge
aspect that they created and bring it
into this and flip it into a you know
more of a fun happy
did you watch season one I did I did
I've never read the source material but
you know a year two years three years
ago in season one came out i watched it
i benched it I really enjoyed it that
first episode just blew my mind that
they were creating a world this vast
yeah if you could take on a new sleeve
after you've been anthony mackie who
would you take on and why you know what
that's a very good question I would take
can it be someone back in the day have
whatever you want I would take I would I
would want to be Michael Michael Jordan
in his prime
oh god I would want to be Michael Jordan
right after the Bulls lost the
championship to Detroit and that next
season he came back and he put on like
15 pounds of muscle and he was on a tear
I want to be Michael Jordan yeah yeah
and I would I would never well I would
leave this leave once he went to the
Wizards but I would definitely be
Michael Jordan for their run in the
night so pre Michael Jordan crying meme
yes but I would also jump into the cry
me Michael Jordan because I was like
y'all Jordan Jordan got hard you know
everybody said Jordan wasn't nice Jordan
got hard Jordan lot of kids
[Laughter]
okay where does your character go in
this season what can we expect um well
this season you know the first season
was about revenge
you know Kovich was very set on finding
now what happened and and why yeah in
this season he figures it out and he
gets to experience his true love you
know this season is very Shakespearean
in the way it's written I equated to
Romeo and Juliet everyone is looking for
that partner that person you know
everyone realizes that the idea of
infinite life is not all it's set up to
be you know when you make a bad decision
or you have a flaw you have to live with
it forever mm-hmm you know so the
ability to be able to humble yourself
and be emotional with someone you trust
is something that I thought was very
important to this character yeah
the critics are praising you in this
role yes sweep yet people are loving you
and this never happened how do you pick
your roles I have a great team yeah and
when my career started I sat down with
my team and we had a conversation about
what we wanted their career to look like
and fortunately for the past 20 years
I've been able to work on that path you
know and I've seen a lot a lot of people
come I've seen a lot of people go but
I've been fortunate enough to where my
team has allowed me my team says no more
than I do so I've been I've been very
lucky blessed with two good doers
awesome great talking to you Anthony
good to see you no Canadian jokes no
Xena and we shine in Canada you didn't
even bring that up I'm just excited went
to avoid you making interviews I love I
enjoyed Canada hey hey